my name is Marco leash ederly and I am
the author of the book of hidden figures
how long does it take for you to write
and then sell the book well writing a
book took all told six years a little
more than six years a little less than
six years actually I started working on
it in December 2010 and really did like
three years of research before putting
together a book proposal finding an
agent and then finding a publisher so so
you know I submitted the book to make
the final draft in July of this year and
the book was published in September
which was just a couple of months before
the movie came out so then how did the
movie come about how was it discovered
and then who wanted to take it on I know
uh Theodore did the screenplay
adaptation yep so what happened is my
literary agent Mackenzie Brady Watson
she got the book proposal into the hands
of this network of book Scouts Lea
somehow it landed on the desk of Donna
gelati who was the producer of the movie
so Donna called me up and this remember
this was only a book proposal at this
time this is like three years ago
so I hadn't finished the book she saw
the book proposal and she said we are
gonna make a movie of this story and so
I thought well cheese I you know I'm
still writing the book it's not even a
book you want option my book proposal I
don't even you know I've never written a
book before but she believed in that
story and you know really took a flyer
on a first-time writer author and that's
that's know the rest is history
everything that she sat on that first
phone call has come true I know that
hidden figures is a true story that many
did not know before the movie came out
what movie did you see at any time in
your life that had the same type of
impact that I'm sure many
we'll feel once they see the film wow
that's a that's a hard question I mean
there's so many movies that are you know
amazing and inspirational you could have
put me on the spot here
you know I'd have to like think do you
think about it you know I think that the
you know in general the thing about
hidden figures is that it is even though
it's a work of nonfiction is totally a
work of imagination you know and I think
the thing about movies that you do
remember that you inspire you is that
they spark your imagination and I think
that's one of the reasons why people are
responding so strongly as they see
something in these women that says to
them wow I just expanded my imagination
of what the world looks like and who I
might be and you would hear them
speaking to you sometimes I mean in
their own from your research did you
hear their I did I really did you know
it's so funny that you asked that
question
I found myself talking to them and
having conversations with them and
dreaming about them and thinking about
them I looked at photos of them to know
what they looked like at different parts
in their life I listened to their their
children talk about the gestures like
Dorothy Vaughn when she got upset she
you know start putting her finger on the
table like this and everybody knew to
back off you know that she was you know
a really like a fearless kind of a woman
you know all of these different things
about them until I really felt like they
had come back to life and they were my
friends you know that they were people
that I really and they really were they
became my companions course in the case
of Katherine Johnson you know Katherine
Johnson is 98 years old she is very much
still with us
and I had just an incredible privilege
to spend time interviewing her and
getting to know her life firsthand
excellent thank you best of luck